we welcome jon wertheim to the show from
60 minutes
and sports associated hey john how you
doing buddy good how are you doing
i'm doing really well i uh uh i'm really
interested
in this book of yours i started looking
kind of at the prospectus
and about this 90-day period you talked
about in 1984 which
was uh a banner year for me i was eight
years old
i was really getting into sports it was
i was a magic johnson fan
larry bird was my dad's favorite player
so they were battling for the first time
michael jordan was coming onto the scene
kind of talk to us about this book uh
glory days that you
recently written yeah i mean it's just
an
incredible amount of really important
sports event
happened that summer i mean you you
named two of them i mean literally a
couple days after
bird beats magic celtic speaks flakers
for the first time in the finals a
couple days later
you've got the 84 draft and this new
commissioner guy david stern goes up
there and calls
bowie elijah on and jordan in that order
and it was the same summer you
had this crazy wrestling event that this
guy vince mcmahon
started that led to wrestlemania then
you had
an olympics that actually made some
money and
wade gretzky finally wins his first
stanley cup and you sort of
the espn this this all sports network
that people kind of like that nobody
really gets
they get sold to abc and realize they
can make a lot of money if they start
charging a subscription fee
which you know sort of became the secret
sauce
um you put it all together and it's just
this incredible summer that not just you
you had these sort of cool events and
coincidences but it really
changed sports as we know it and i kind
of i kind of use the uh jordan's kind of
my
my symbolic figure where he starts the
summer is this kind of schlubby
college kid who'd rather be going to
school but his coach is making him
go to the nba a year early and he ends
up
you know driving around chicago in a
limousine with a gold medal around his
neck
and uh you know a multi-million dollar
signature shoe deal
and sports in general kind of traced
that same arc that summer the amazing
nature of how sports have changed and
this may have been
one of those catalysts 1984 that really
kind of put it
in that direction we watched uh the
french open take place over the two
weeks at roland garros
and um to start it all off we heard from
naomi osaka
uh explain to the world which has got to
be incredibly difficult to do it in a
transparent and vulnerable way
uh as as as considered as one of the
greatest tennis players in the world at
this time that she was dealing with some
mental illness
some some issues around anxiety and some
depression and she talked about how it
was
uh how it was exacerbated by the
post-match
conversations with the media and things
of that nature and she was going to
choose not to do that
this year and the immediate response
from the organizers of the french open
was was a public shaming and
the backup from as well as journalists
i think helped qualm the issue but then
again john
we watched this weekend and for some
inexplicable reason the organizers for
the french open when it was all said and
done
felt it necessary to get the last word
in
and kind of publicly shame her again in
front of everybody about how they did
everything right
and how this wasn't necessarily um
as bad as what everybody was making it
out to be
uh you you nailed it i mean the idea of
going through
what had happened these last few weeks
and you finally get the chance to say
we're sorry we acted disproportionately
we're now realizing that this is really
about a you know a young woman who's
in a bit of a damaged place right now
and needs some time and then we
paid too much of you you have that
opportunity and you use it instead to
double down
it's um well welcome to tennis i mean it
was pretty disappointing and it was um
you wonder who's handling the the crisis
management there
because to go through with everybody in
the sport went through and come out of
it and have an open microphone to sort
of
say say we're sorry we overreacted
instead basically say yeah
no regrets here pretty uh pretty
mind-boggling but
i think you framed it really well which
is like can you imagine that never mind
in 1984 i mean just
imagine 20 years ago an athlete at the
top of her game like that
making a declaration saying i'm dealing
with anxiety and some mental health
challenges
um the fact that naomi osaka felt
comfortable enough to be so public
i i think is one of the few you know
we're looking for silver lining here
the fact that she felt sufficiently
comfortable and not stigmatized
to be that forthright about what she's
going through i think maybe a
little bit of a glimmer but this was
this was not a proud moment for uh
for tennis it wasn't and it it is for
her
it is for to your point removing that
stigma and i've been searching for that
for a long long time you know i grew up
in a cowboy culture in montana and then
in the
locker rooms of college football in the
nfl and i'd never
i never saw another man uh step up and
say hey i'm really struggling here
uh i need some help um therefore when it
when it and it hit me and i was going
through those things i didn't have any
guidance i didn't know what to do
and what she was able to do in a moment
in front of the whole world she just
gave
millions and millions and millions of
young girls
who struggle with mental illness or
things of any nature
the confidence to come out and do it and
that's what should be applauded and
that's what i would have loved to seen
from the french open organizers about
we applaud her for taking such a strong
stance about her
medical and mental health uh this is
going to go a long ways
in how we go about things and how we
help people in the
in the future i'm totally with you and i
would say she also
provided some vocabulary yep you know i
mean i think people
have probably been struggling with what
she's struggling with and just didn't
know how to uh
how to characterize it i mean i think
one of the dirty secrets here is
these press conferences yeah it's about
the media and you get some quotes and it
helps publicize the tournament but also
you know when like belichick stands up
in front of the dunkin donuts
uh placards you look at the french open
and they've got
bnp pair you know they've got a bank
behind them they've got sponsored water
bottles
i i think this is a lot about a
tournament saying wait a second we
sell these sessions this is part of what
we make money off of this is like uh
bonus dvd footage we
put these clips on social media and
everyone can see our sponsors
i i think people may have overlooked
that the tournament has a real
financial interest this isn't about
first amendment and media rights as much
as it's about protecting something
that has value to the tournament but um
yeah i mean again i was surprised that
all the tournaments reacted the way they
did i thought it was really out of
proportion i think if you knew naomi
osaka you knew she wasn't
you know this wasn't the entitled
athlete who was trying to buy her way
out of an obligation this was a damaged
individual this is someone dealing with
with some issues who was sort of
spiritually broken right now i thought
it was really clumsy the way they
responded but
then two weeks after to not
douse the fire but basically double down
on what had been such a flawed
approach it was it was pretty stunning
to read those quotes it was
it was definitely thank you for your
contribution there john wertheim
from 60 minutes in sports illustrated
let's let's go to the men's draw the
men's side of things
um i i was having i was at a a
three-year-old's birthday party
on sunday and uh i looked at
uh um you know the feed on espn and i
saw that
novak uh djokovic came back from two
sets down to to win in three and i just
thought it was so impressive
i've always really enjoyed his tennis
and during a generation of tennis with
federer and
rafa and now him i thought it was so
impressive his 19th grand slam title but
then i had
i mentioned it to a couple other parents
at the table there and i said novak came
back and won he won the french open
and all of their reactions were like oh
oh
and he arguably
in a year or two will have more grand
slam
victories than anybody else because he's
most likely roger and rafa are going to
are done at 20. they may you know it may
be
a resurrection somewhere at some time
especially the french open for rafa but
novak has a chance to be the greatest
tennis player of all time
and i've never seen somebody who was in
the goat conversation
be disliked as much as him is that
something you felt on tour or is that
just more of a thing
kind of americanized over here where
we've seen it publicized
uh with his behavior and everything like
that um or is that actually something
that's that's a real feeling out there
on the tour
yeah man um it's it's a live issue it's
a great question and i feel like you
know i mean you if the guy in serbia
could run for president tomorrow
right i mean he certainly has pockets of
popularity i i wish i remember i'd
credit them i wish i remember who's
so someone compared drunk which is sort
of like the detroit pistons right so
you've got the
you got the lakers and the celtics you
got bird and magic you sort of pick your
tribe
and you have that with better nadal and
you know the truth is you really kind of
like the other one too
and all of a sudden here comes this
party crasher and they're not
particularly
you know artistically pleasing i mean
it's it's not quite
detroit bad boys tennis but sort of like
who's this third guy
wrecking up this this nice rivalry we
had so i thought djokovic sort of always
had that against him as like the third
guy in the party
um he does some things that aren't
necessarily only so so admirable but
he's not like the bad boy of tennis i
mean he's a nice guy and i think one
thing is
really kind of wild is he he really
wants to be liked
i mean it would crush him to hear what
you just said from that birthday party
like he wants everyone to like him
if he just said you know what i'm jimmy
connors or whatever i'm mike tyson and
you know like me or hate me i don't care
it would be easy he really wants
affection he really wants roger
federer's popularity level and i think
that only kind of makes people
withhold it um so it's yeah it's a weird
thing i mean this guy is
um this guy's gonna retire with the most
majors he has a winning record
head-to-head against the other two guys
he's i mean just sort of you name more
weeks at number one you sort of make the
statistical case and it's really hard
not to conclude
that he's the best ever but there's just
that lacking
element personally among so many fans
that you know you suspect djokovic
himself would trade in a few of those
majors for a little more popularity
or else you know part of you want to say
listen man just wear the black hat just
be the pro wrestling heel
right but he doesn't want that so it's a
weird thing where
in terms of tennis he's incredible in
some pockets he's very popular but he
hasn't been able to
equal what veteran nadal have done in
terms of sort of appeal
and you kind of feel like it
it really bothers him and you know who
knows i mean there's maybe he turns
around i mean we see this all the time
right where
the older athletes get the more
affection we have for them and you
start off as the villain and end up as
the hero but yeah it's a real wrinkle in
this that he's doing amazing things as a
player he just hasn't
got the public affection the way the
other two guys have
we're speaking with john wertheim from
sports illustrated executive
uh editor as well as the 60 minutes
correspondent let's talk about the play
uh you know you know pretty much
dominated in that second set
and then you know he flipped a switch
again and went on to
beat uh his opponent who was looking for
his first
grand slam victory uh in in the next
three sets
uh his last two matches at the french
open four hours and 11 minutes each his
dominance his stamina uh he he is
he is setting the stage for him being
considered the greatest
tennis player of all time and he
continues to do it
are you are you an mma fan by any
champion i am
so there is no hole in this guy's game
there is no weakness there is nothing
that he can't do just as well as
everyone else
and that makes him i mean it's not even
a separate category i mean all the fact
that he has no weakness makes him so
mentally strong
and he just goes out there assuming
whatever you're going to throw at him
you may have him in a really you may get
him in a triangle but he's going to
figure out a way to get out of it and
once he gets that one
whiff of weakness once he senses your
doubt
it's game over and i mean it's just
nothing you sort of say
how do i beat this guy because there is
just no hole in his game
he's as good on the ground as he is in
stand-up he's as good
serving as he is returning there's
nothing he doesn't do
just as well as the other guy and that
gives him this sort of mental
impregnability so uh he's a really
really hard guy to beat
and i don't know if it's stopping
anytime soon it's so much fun to watch
uh we want to thank uh john
wurtheim for joining us uh go out and
grab his book glory days about the 90
days in 1984
that really changed sports and culture
together john thanks for taking time to
be with us today
and talk to a little tennis with me you
got it that was fun
thanks man you bet hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here